I'm going to kick off with the question
everyone wants to know which is Boris
Johnson do you want to be Prime Minister
what I want is to change the current
state of the brexit negotiations away
from where they are which is the mired
in confusion we've got the EU rejecting
the checkers proposals I think there are
freely unsatisfactory in the problem
with checkers is that in order to
resolve and what are actually easily
fixable problems but borders it keeps us
in the --use regulatory framework
forever and probably also in the customs
union that means basically that we have
failed in our duty to the people to take
back control you've set yourself up with
a very different plan as a different
person that could negotiate brexit and
do you think you'd do a better job
negotiating no I think no I think that
Teresa has been on the right lines and
indeed she's doing the right thing in a
sense today by trying to get rid of this
Irish backstop that we mistakenly agreed
in December the 8th last year but then
do a big free trade that's that's the
way you're very clear that she needs to
check because lots of your colleagues
agree with you if she won't chop
checkers must the party chuck huh no
what needs to happen is there needs to
be a change of policy no it's not about
that this is about the direction that
we're going in and my anxiety really is
that you know yes it's true formally
speaking that the EU has rejected
checkers but be careful but there's
actually it's it's a great deal for them
and I just want to make an ID any police
the checkers deal is actually a worry to
be agreed with the EU would be a
political triumph for Brussels because
what it would show is the United Kingdom
for all its power might for the 2
trillion
pound economy that we have fifth biggest
economy in the world but in the end when
it came to it we were unable to reclaim
economic
and so and so so there's that that's
that that's the risk I think there is
there are some people on my side of the
argument whose kind of think are
Brussels will never will never wear it I
think it's a disastrous option but III
fear that Brussels might make it but
lots of your colleagues are saying that
she should step aside after March next
year that she's the right person for
brexit but not the right person for
beyond what do you think this is not the
issue for for me it really really isn't
I don't forget what I had to do better I
was there in the leave campaign and I
played a role in that and I argued for a
vision of Britain it's a fantastic
opportunity for us and I did argue for
that within cabinet for a very long time
yeah and sometimes you know I would
sense that things weren't going my way
and it was very frustrating and I would
intervene publicly and I'm getting you
know and I read pieces and made speeches
and so on and so forth
but I kept thinking that we would get
there in the end and I kicked in
assurances do you think she should leave
the party was the next general election
that's a matter for for her and she said
herself that should go on for as long as
this is it is it is so important that
people understand that this is about
trying to get breaks it back on track
and I think I think it's about trust and
how people see us so I feel it obviously
very personally because I was part of it
yeah sister Rachel said of you he knows
life's a competition he always wants to
be on top you yourself once said that
your ambition was to be wild king that's
according to Rachel yeah yeah honestly I
can honestly say that if we if we can
get this right now and I do believe
there's a very good chance that we will
and we can revert to an optimistic self
confident vision for this country can
achieve my cut will run over I can't
really walk just it has
can't quite hated though you described
her grexit plan as a suicide vest
wrapped around Britain do you regret
those well I think there is I'm afraid
in what we're trying to do with the sari
to revert to because I know you think
it's a technicality but assembly a third
Irish backstop would effectively give
the cannot explain now okay
but explain I think it's not really
prime ministerial language is that
that's for others to judge much I felt
it was what I think that the problem
with the Irish backstop is is very
accurately it's very I don't I stand by
what I said I look like I stand by what
I say in all these if you go back over
25 years of my writing and speaking you
will find I'm trying to say something
radically different from what people
imputed to me and what I would ask you
our viewers to do is actually to go and
look at the models concerns there is an
element of choice for calling describing
work wearing box at bank robbers and
letter boxes you now under investigation
will you apologize for that okay as I
said stand by what I wrote I urge my
friends and colleagues to look carefully
at what I wrote I think he will find
invariably that there is an element of
confection indignation about things that
I've said that a wrenched out of out of
context and in this particular context I
think possibly just throw this thought
out there that's what is going on is
that people do feel a slight sense of
uneasiness about the direction the more
than a slight sense of uneasiness real
alarm about the direction of the brexit
negotiations and they are conscious that
I have a strong view about that and I
think they're perhaps reacting to that
as much as to anything else I mean used
to be
well III have to say this is nothing new
people do take things out of context I
urge people to look at the articles is
concerned and and and actually that's
more importantly to look at what I'd
been trying to say today and the better
way forward is to go with a super Canada
deal that would be fantastic
for this country who in my view set us
on a course of prosperity for a long
time now I would I would like the I
would like the Prime Minister to get
back to her initial position and to
deliver on that vision and thereby to
deliver on the hopes of the people who
voted to leave in 2016